ladies and gentlemen Outback developers
welcome to NDC and now straight from the
mean streets of Harvard we proudly
welcome the man the myth the developer
the legend James mikedz
all right it's the mic on can everybody
hear me good all right excellent so as I
was so accurately introduced my name is
James mikans and today I'm going to talk
to you about my life as a developer I'm
going to describe these some very deeply
personal stories about how I struggle
with hardware with software with poor
internet connections I'm in a feud with
Taylor Swift right now okay my life is a
mess and today I'm going to open a
portal into this nightmare struggle
because I think that you can relate to
my suffering so if you're like me you
wake up sometimes and you say why did I
decide to work in technology
why didn't I study the humanities and
the obvious answer is that if you study
the humanities then modern society has
said that your life was worth nothing
right my self-esteem is far too fragile
to deal with me being a constant
disappointment to everyone who surrounds
me alright so for example consider this
guy right so he majored in philosophy
he's fluent in three languages he has
excellent communication skills and most
importantly he loved you for who you are
okay even though you have flaws because
those flaws ultimately make you special
and lead to personal growth okay so what
a society say about this guy throw him
in a dumpster
no job for this guy okay in contrast
let's consider this abominable snowman
okay
his resume has some pros and it has some
cons so on the pro side
he knows C++ on the con side he will
definitely eat you right he's gonna
start from the bottom up so that you'll
be able to feel the pain as he consumes
you
so what does society say about this guy
hire this guy okay we'll put him in a
special room you can't eat anyone or
we'll just let him eat that guy in the
dumpster nobody loved that guy anyway
right so it's a mercy killing do you see
what I'm saying so literally the current
economy would prefer to give money to an
abominable snowman instead of a
humanities major everyday The Wall
Street Journal has an article with the
title like computer scientists jobs
increased by 15% history majors
routinely tortured by pirates nobody
cares nobody sheds a single tear okay
everything is being driven by these
business walks and these algorithm nerds
right this is why modern music in fact
is quite terrible you see back in the
day here's how you'd make an album right
you take your band you go to a farmhouse
or an abandoned castle you drink some
tea you read some poetry and maybe take
some cocaine things happen whatever I'm
not gonna judge people but the point is
that you were inspired by your creative
muse okay you inspire by the brightest
fires of the human spirit in contrast
here's how a Rihanna album gets made you
just import the Rihanna module okay
it's available on NPM it's a node module
you can just download it and run it
yourself as you can see in the bottom
left-hand corner of the screen the
inputs to the Rihanna function or a set
of studio musicians in a series of
unoriginal chord progressions at about
128 beats per minute because that kind
of things sound like the stuff that you
want to dance - I don't know it comes
from your caveman part of your soul and
the output is basically twelve songs
three generic music videos and a minimum
concert ticket price about seventy five
dollars so this is what happens when you
live in a world that overemphasizes
algorithms now you might be thinking to
yourself James you've stirred something
up in me you've inspired me I'm gonna go
out and become a musician
okay I'm gonna grow my hair long and
we're cool other jackets and create
music that comes from the heart and I
would say that's really great for me to
hear but cut your hair you need to eat
okay don't be crazy all right you need
healthcare I don't want you to get a
paper cut then you have to go die in a
ditch because you can't afford to buy
antibiotics okay so just think about
this I care about you okay I care about
you and some of you may come from
socialized countries well healthcare is
free I come from the land that has a lot
of freedom but not actually healthcare
a little bit awkward baby steps we're
kind of getting there
basically paper cuts are a big problem
so anyways this is the real reason that
I work in technology computers are okay
but I really just need to earn enough
money so that when the Mad Max world
becomes reality I can afford to buy one
of those cars that has the bendy dudes
on it because I feel like having dudes
on bendy poles is gonna be a key metric
for success in the year 2025 one Society
has killed all the people who studied
Romance languages and for those of you
who are actually listening please go to
my LinkedIn profile and endorse me for
having dudes on bendy balls
there's no rush in that endorsement I
just need you to do this by the time the
year 2025 rolls around so thank you for
your help
so anyways speaking of Mad Max I'm
actually glad to be here in Australia I
do have to admit though I was a little
bit afraid to come here because you know
from the outside Australia is portrayed
as this crazy larger-than-life type
place where danger is constantly around
the corner so for example I did a little
research and I discovered that in
Australia there unmarked holes
everywhere okay you just you're walking
around what happened to Jason unmarked
hole we don't talk about Jason anymore
so I'm not actually sure how common
these things actually are but I think
that Australians are actually very
amused by Australia's reputation and I
think that they like to exaggerate the
danger of Australia to outsiders so for
example I have an Australian friend this
is true in his his name is Ryan I've
actually changed his name to protect his
innocence and also I'm not going to show
you Ryan's real face instead I'm going
to show you a photo of paranoid Hugh
Jackman with the mullet
I feel like this photo really captures
Ryan's attitude quite well so I do a
Google hangout with Ryan I say hey guess
what man I'm coming to Australia and
Ryan says that's great but don't forget
the ruse control the night
and so I'm kind of shocked when I hear
this I'm like Ryan what is the route and
he says kangaroos mate they hang out by
the petrol station so they can trample
on your car the route cannot be
contained the Roos evil the room must be
destroyed
by the way welcome to Australia all
right
that's what I always loved about all
these sort of descriptions of the
country it's like things are really
crazy but we're so glad to have you here
so then Ryan actually continued and he
said by the way most of Australia is
constantly on fire take a look at this
map hit City City fire as far as the eye
can see it's like that red eye of
Jupiter but right here on earth welcome
to Australia
by the way when you put on your shoes be
sure to watch out for the shoes - I said
man we do have these huge spiders let's
let the shoe spider so my friend says
here's what you got to know about
spiders in Australia the shoe spider
it's the size of a car the car spider is
the size of a house and the house spider
is the size of a tiny speck of dust so
it can float inside your ear and trample
on your brain by the way have you heard
of this all lockpicks so at this point
I'm thinking Ryan you stop telling me
all this stuff I'm going to go to
Australia I'm sure that everything's
gonna be fine and I'm happy to report
that I've only seen three Sarlacc pit
since I've been here that feels very
exciting to me I think I'm gonna be okay
so anyways one thing that amused me
actually as I was talking to Ryan was
that Ryan talked about Australia in the
same way that MongoDB users talk about
MongoDB
do you know what I'm saying like MongoDB
users will tell you these insane stories
about MongoDB and you'd think that all
these stories would end with MongoDB
being uninstalled and destroyed from
space but somehow people continue to use
MongoDB and apparently have a great time
about it right so this is why I think
that anyone who performs DevOps for
MongoDB should actually speak with an
Australian accent so for example instead
of saying MongoDB queries don't always
return on matching documents you can say
sometimes dad shows up drunk to work and
that's just the way it has to be instead
of saying that MongoDB can return stale
versions of documents you can say in the
app back time is the fluid and
subjective concepts
look at this didgeridoo here did reduce
have no versions instead of saying the
MongoDB can return garbage data from
writes that never should have occurred
you can say on Thursdays
MongoDB replaces every fifth bit in your
database with an angry Komodo dragon so
I don't know I guess the whole point of
this rant is that life is tough life is
tough sometimes your databases I guess
just have to be filled with poisonous
lizards this is the life that we've
chosen as software developers and I
think it's actually tough to be a
programmer you're constantly surrounded
by failure all the time your hard work
and misbehave your software can crash
users are always doing unexpected things
and in the middle of this chaos software
developers are expected to constantly
improve their output to produce more and
more lines of bug-free code every day
and so everybody has a different theory
about how to improve developer
productivity you can use pair
programming a wizard-based scrum
programming or agile cosplay Waterfall
programming you can just buy a ton of
monitors so that when people visit you
don't know that you lost your virginity
in a chat room you can use Emacs or
sublime you can be a real hero and use
notepad because syntax highlighting
she week okay and if your source code
file doesn't fit in a note than your
modularity sucks but everyone I think
who's a real developer I think everyone
in this room knows there's only one true
metric for how good a developer is
window placement okay it's the only
metric that counts window placement
evaluates how well a developer places
her application windows within her
desktop environment so for example look
at this window placement here it's
amateurish
it's naive look at all the clumsy
overlapping so the poor use of negative
space for God's sake look at this file
explorer I don't even know what
directory it's open to this is insane
now let's consider the window placement
of a professional developer now you're
talking yeah Papa likes it Papa likes it
you got separate browser windows for
different web searches you're performing
you've got multiple open chat sessions
with both your co-workers and your
personal friends you've got a code
editor boom you've got a terminal window
yearning for your input right there
you've got the gossip site minimized but
just an alt tab away so that when your
boss leaves your office you can go and
see what all people are doing in
Hollywood it's very exciting this my
friends is the window placement of a
professional developer now as you'll
know when you achieve this type of
window placement you'll exist in a
special plane of existence it's like all
of your senses are magnified and
strengthened with a single mouse click
or alt tab you have 67 terabytes of
information at your control right it's a
great feeling but after about five days
of having optimal window placement and
you'll be doing some programming and
then you'll see a little icon pop up in
the lower right hand corner of your
monitor restarts required for updates oh
god no no no when you when you've
achieved perfect window placement
rebooting your computer is equivalent to
a post nuclear apocalypse right
civilization is completely destroyed
there's no language there's no music
there's no dance it's impossible to
think about rebuilding your life in such
a barren world and that's why when
you've achieved perfect window
placements rebooting must be avoided for
as long as possible right so at first
it's very easy to do you minimize the
pop-up window and you go about your
business
but those messages from your machine
become more and more urgent if you don't
reboot your machine this small child
will never be loved by his parents and
you're like oh well good luck with all
the sadness maybe you should join the
army work out some of that anger because
your father never loved you I can't help
you I've got perfect window placement
I'm better than you in a very real sense
okay I'm sorry I'm not I'm not sorry
okay this this is how you feel when you
have that perfect window placement right
so the days go on and you still haven't
rebooted and at this point your machine
starts to become unstable every one of
your cores is running at a hundred
percent utilization it's all kernel-mode
activity files are being opened and
closed and read and written for no
reason at all all of your Bluetooth
devices are on your machine doesn't have
any Bluetooth devices and at this point
your machine begins to become physically
hot if your machine is a laptop it isn't
comfortable to put on your lap the fan
is constantly blowing just hot air onto
your lap there is now a 97% chance that
you are sterile your reproductive organs
have been barbecued out of this plane of
existence and sit to a spirit world
where gonads have formed their own
civilization free from the failings of
traditional human society and this all
sounds very terrible but there is a
bright side you've got perfect window
place
so that's still pretty cool now this
point you've actually avoided rebooting
for a month and your operating system is
queued up 83 critical security patches
which fix devastating security holes in
your machine but you can't install
aeneas batches because your fuses are
doing your machine day 45 without
rebooting you come back from lunch and
you discover the entire northwestern
quadrant of your screen is gone it just
doesn't work anymore it's like a
migraine aura just unfathomable pixels
coming in and out of existence and it
kind of sucks but guess what
still got perfect window placement and
three-quarters of the screen right
you've got two copies of everything open
anyway so who cares if you lose a
quadrant right and so you continue about
your day however about an hour later
things take a turn for the worse now
when you look in the northwestern
quadrant it's filled with that kid who's
always trying to escape from Japanese
televisions and mirrors all of your
input devices at this point have now
been corrupted by Satan so whenever you
try to draw anything with your mouse you
just draw pentagrams on the screen for
no reason and then when you try to alt
tab and then one of your perfectly
placed windows your machine just
displays that quote from Nietzsche about
staring into the void and so finally
after 57 days without a reboot you are
forced to reboot your laptop by
physically taking out its battery and
then throwing it into a river you wave
goodbye to it like a lover and you think
of all the great times that you shared
your perfect window placement is now
gone but it's not forgotten and much
like a Phoenix it will rise again now of
course because you've delayed all these
security updates hackers are stolen your
credit cards you can no longer afford a
Phoenix but you get the point the
metaphor is beautiful
much like your window placement used to
be now some of you might have noticed
that the machine in this story is a
Windows machine and I'm sure that some
of you are thinking James you'd have
fewer problems if you used a Linux
machine instead of a Windows machine and
my response to that is have you ever
used Linux Linux is never the end
to the question what life choice would
reduce the number of life problems that
I have right now right Linux is very
nice if you like editing configuration
files that are poorly documented it's
also nice if you want to desperately
search for device drivers for your
devices and it's also nice if you want
to in fact write those device drivers
because they either don't exist
or they do exist but you can only
download them from Eastern European
websites which may be fronts for human
trafficking Linux is also very nice if
you like kernel mailing lists which
frequently resemble a bar fight or an
awkward family reunion in which your
uncle unleashes the profanity filter
irate about the proper use of tab space
and commenting formats and everybody has
to listen to this because everybody is
running the operating system called
uncle X so hashtag uncomfortable Linux
is also nice if you'd like to use GUI
managers which are often
indistinguishable from brutalist french
architecture from the 1960s any guesses
which one of these is a window manager
as it turns out both of them are window
managers the one on the right is called
genome brutally and it will be available
with the upcoming a boon to distro so go
out there and check it out so don't get
me wrong I actually like Linux I have
several machines that run Linux natively
but I do think that it's funny when I
meet people and they say why isn't Linux
more popular on the desktop and the
answer is it the real impediment to
Linux on the desktop is Linux on the
desktop right that's the big problem
right people who say that Linux on the
desktop is right around the corner or
like members of a religious cult who
keep miss predicting the data the world
is going to end right it's like the day
the world is totally going to end on
Tuesday and then Tuesday rolls around
and they're like I totally
misinterpreted that cave painting the
world's actually gonna in next Tuesday
then the Monday before that is when
Linux on the desktop is going to become
real so it should be cool so news I
digress where were we I yes so I had
just been forced to reboot my machine so
I reboot my machine and my operating
system finally upgrades itself I'm
greeted with an empty lonely desktop and
I begin the painful process of
reconstructing
perfect window placement but soon I
noticed a different icon in the corner
of my desktop it says that the Adobe PDF
reader would like to update itself now
this notification raises a very
disturbing question why would my PDF
reader ever need to update itself here's
what I need my PDF reader to do display
PDF documents that's it now you know
that the rest of this list is blankness
it is the absence of additional list
items right a PDF reader should be very
simple because displaying a PDF document
is a timeless operation which never
requires an update it should be like the
plus sign right you would never think to
yourself what's two plus two
hold on let me update the plus sign I
just need to download about 48 megabytes
and new plus sign semantics okay that's
cool the update is done and now two plus
two equals the color shamrock green wow
that's so amazing it's a plus sign for
the modern generation it's not your
parents plus sign right this of course
is stupid and dumb all right it's a
reading a PDF file should be very simple
it should never change so why is my PDF
reader always updating the reason if you
allow me to answer my own question
because I've thought about it is that
the Adobe PDF reader has an infinite
number of features and new features are
being added every second right
so is it allowable by the laws of
physics from a PDF reader to add
multiple digital signatures to my PDF
file and then I can add comments to the
passes and the PDF file that I find
interesting and then Anna would say my
PDF file with an embedded video and then
encrypt the entire PDF file so that
after the PDF file has been
automatically uploaded to the cloud only
my very best very special friends can
read it is this allowable by the laws of
physics yes
is this allowable by the laws of human
decency No
right so I was talking about this topic
to one of my friends and he said that
all these features are there because a
lot of enterprise customers use these
features but if your corporation uses
all of these features what is your
business model okay are you in the
business of ridiculousness
right let me give you some life advice
okay if you're protecting your
mission-critical data using encrypted
PDF files in the cloud
the Russians already know what you're
doing okay
they weren't fooled by that at all just
hot knife through butter
very hot knife very cuttable butter okay
so Adobe Reader sort of cracks me up
because if you think about it it
represents the weaponization of
complexity everything has to be a
platform now it has to enable this vast
constellation of experiences and
feelings it's ridiculous PDFs are
supposed to be simple right here's my
mental model that I think is shared by a
lot of people for how PDFs are created
and used somewhere there's a monk
sitting at a castle his face illuminated
by candlelight this monk has an idea an
idea that he wants to share with the
world he goes to his closet he takes out
a single scroll of sheepskin paper the
sheep's name was Steve we all love Steve
even though we eventually turned his
skin in the paper and his hair in the
novelty sweaters it was a complicated
situation but Steve understood he was a
hero there were no tears from Steve
anyways the monk takes the skin of his
friend Steve writes down his great idea
you see the monk is employed by a
consulting company that produces
completely meaningless white papers
about technology 3d printers result in
more 3d things being printed big data's
bigger than you think
unless you already know what the
adjective big means there will be 27
gajillion IOT devices by the time you
finish reading this sentence basically
just take the up into the right grab and
label the axes whatever you want and now
you can write for Forrester that's
basically how that works
so anyways this is the miracle of life
just the way that God intended so the
monk takes his sheepskin paper scans it
he has all the content digitized a PDF
is born into this world that PDF is
posted on a website I download it and I
open that PDF with the ideal PDF reader
I only need four simple commands page
down page up zoom out and zoom in that's
all that I need for my PDF reader so
let's see what kind of tools I get from
the modern adobe reader Jesus Christ
look at all that this is what Tony Stark
sees when he's looking to the eyes of
the Iron Man suit right Jorma barded
with all these colors and these icons
and expanding menus I mean look at all
this stuff I can do I can optimize and
stamp and measure and redact I can put
JavaScript in my PDF that one's too easy
even for me to make fun of okay just
gonna use that as an exercise for the
reader right but one thing that does
actually seem cool is that I can put
accessibility features into my PDF file
so that people who are blind can read
the PDF using a speech synthesizer so
that actually seems pretty neat so I
decided to click on that accessibility
icon and see what happens I'm taken to a
website which tells me I have to pay
money to make my PDF file accessible
that's actually kind of messed up right
so should have the ability to create
accessible PDFs the part of the free
Adobe software I can just imagine
Wolfgang von Adobe or whatever sitting
somewhere the executive office counting
all the money then an angry mob of blind
people show up in his office and they
knock the desk off his land and then a
lamp off his desk and he says now you're
playing in our world right now to be
clear I'm not encouraging blind people
to form gangs and commit vandalism okay
in case any of your news reporters don't
tweet this snapchat at whatever the kids
do these days I'm just saying that Adobe
PDF reader has a ton of features that
most people don't meet I think and the
result is that Adobe constantly has to
update itself to add new features and
patch the old ones so by the way this is
a pretty uplifting talk huh just a list
of things that I hate you're lucky the
organized
only gave me 30 minutes otherwise I'd be
up here Fidel Castro style in an hour 15
t to nano VMS are a tool of capitalist
oppression the workers deserve em three
double X largest from each according to
their ability to each according to their
poorly understood understood workload
characteristics which may not in fact
need the most expensive VM right
San Francisco belonged to the San
Franciscans of the new variety who used
is efficacious push out the original San
Franciscans anyways what was I talking
about
oh yes so I was talking about things I
don't like it was very easy for me to
recover my train of thought there so
what don't I like well one thing I don't
like is that I feel like there are too
many software frameworks these days so
back in the good old days there was just
one software framework and it was called
lib see ok back in the good old days
your application consisted of things you
did yourself other things you did
yourself and that was it
people were hard-working and they knew
the value of re-implementing the wheel
okay there was no sharing of high level
frameworks if you didn't like Lib C then
you go home because that's how things
work around here our little town is
everything we want
we got a restaurant we got a pond we got
a place where you can sit we got Lib C
ok that's all that we need but now these
developers these days they're so
newfangled and when I hear about all
this talk about this framework and that
framework I just want to cry big angry
tears right so whenever I go to Silicon
Valley
I hang out in the coffee shops I always
hear the developers talking about
frameworks one of them says hey how's
the app coming along and the other one
says oh it's going pretty good pretty
good
we just migrated from AWS to cloud i/o
that IO IO they have 17 tens of
availability they also have data centers
located in outer space the center of the
earth and the Louvre how exciting
so it's pretty awesome if I do say so
myself I a store all of my application
data in kitchen sink which is a non
relational no sequel semi relational
JSON document table store
it supports all possible schema types
natively it only has indices if you want
it to and if it only has in this season
everything becomes an NDC so it's just
very fast it's like super convenient
then of course the support continuous
testing and development I set up an
instance of you to real MVP which
simultaneously executes my post commit
hooks and also sends me an inspirational
quote of the day from a famous movie
star or an older European gentleman who
lived in the 1700s and I also put all my
configuration data inside a Gandalf the
other person says oh I've heard of that
you mean Gandalf the Grey no Gandalf the
white it's totally incompatible with
Gandalf the Grey the data format change
from XML to JSON it's just a big mess a
big mess anyways though of course my
application needs a monitoring
infrastructure to ensure that all of my
code is running properly now for that I
use drunken frenemy from high school as
a service this is actually a
crowdsourcing platform that harnesses
the power of all the losers that I knew
from high school you see people are
constantly monitoring my infrastructure
in sending me irritating late-night text
messages about the health net
infrastructure they also text me and
they asked whether they should stay in
their current relationship and the nice
thing no but then they say but I love
her so much that I'm like we should try
to make it work and they say but it
hurts so bad I don't know what to tell
them because they've been in this place
so many times it's not healthy anymore
you know and I'm saying anyways back to
my infrastructure so I collect my mobile
payments using triangle and I collect my
web payments using Bill buddy and I
detect payment fraud using Pokemon know
which allows me to look at my financial
statements and see if any of them are
being used by pokemons associated with
financial crime such as Russian mob
syndicate Pikachu and Kim jong-un means
foreign currency Bulbasaur so the
developer on the right finishes the
description of the application stack and
he says so what do you think now if this
world were fair the developer on the
Left would transform into some type of
zombie and just devour the developer on
the right unfortunately we do not live
in this world so we suffer what we must
so I hear all these conversations at the
coffee shop and I grudgingly conclude
that I should
probably learn some more about these new
technologies so I opened up my laptop
and I try to do some research in
Internet however when I use the wireless
network the connection is just really
really bad right it's horrible I'm
trying to open up a tutorial on YouTube
I'm not getting 10 20 P I'm not even
getting 720p I'm getting 7-piece ok I
didn't even know this was an option I
have three and a half pixels okay one of
them isn't even parallel to the horizon
this makes no sense this is how a
salamander perceives the world
salamanders cannot understand tutorials
on large-scale web services I feel like
I'm not getting a lot from this tutorial
so I make this sad sad noise of defeat
and then I noticed that the only person
in San Francisco who is older than 35
it's now leaning over my shoulder this
man turns to me and I can tell that he's
extremely wise and knowledgeable and and
he says I noticed that you were looking
for something on the web maybe you could
find the same information at a library
and I say I'm not trying to learn about
the causes for the French Revolution I
need to learn about a web protocol that
was invented five minutes ago do you see
it I'm saying right when you take the
internet away from you as a developer
I'm literally ruined as a person okay
it's like you've stripped away all of my
fundamental dignity okay I'm getting two
kilobytes per second over this wireless
connection I tried to load my Facebook
page I got something from a CSI episode
okay this is terrible
okay so my timeline my news feed and my
friend list have all merged into
something that supports neither time nor
news nor friends okay I can't live in a
world like this okay so can you spare me
some sympathy can you try to understand
where I'm coming from and the man closes
his book and he leans over and he says
that's not really what I came here to
tell you today and then he takes off a
mask and it's a time-travelling grace
hop what a convenient anecdote with
which to end my talk time travel is real
Grace Hopper has access to it and she's
using it to deliver common-sense wisdom
to the confused technocratic elite my
name is James Mickens thank you for your
time